[موسيقى]
خطوات تسير في الارض اليوم وتقلب التاريخ
لتصل في رحلتها الثامنه على خطى العرب الى
صفحه قريبه بعيده عيد اليحيى تتبع في هذه
الرحله خطى القبائل العربيه واشعارها
واثار الرحاله والعلماء لتحديد الخريطه
الاولى لحجر اليمامه ومراحل توسعها حتى
اصبحت الرياض بامتدادها الذي نعرفه اليوم
[موسيقى]
الجهه الغربيه لجبل الطويق المهيب هي جبل
العارض عارض يعترض الشرق والغرب وخلف
جدرانه الشاهقه تتربع حجر اليمامه بسهولها
ووديانها كما جرت العاده ذهب فريق العربيه
الى الخطوه الاولى للانسان في هذه القصه
الى بوابه حجر اليمامه الى طريق القديه
واعرضت اليمامه واسمرت
كاسياف بايدي مصلحين خطوه بعد خطوه رسمت
هذه السلسله الوثائقيه خريطه بدايتها وصول
بني حنيفه من الحجاز الى نجد واستقرارهم
في وادي العرض الذي تحول فيما بعد الى ما
يعرف بوادي حنيفه ثم تاسيس الدوله
السعوديه الاولى فالثانيه حتى نشات الدوله
الثالثه
على ضفاف وادي حنيفه العظيم الذي ياتي من
الشمال الغربي لمدينه الرياض من مرتفعات
جبل العارض ويمتد في مسافه 100 كيلو متر
وصلنا الان الى وادي بوظه اباط قديما وهو
من روافد وادي حنيفه الاساسي اكيد ان
الاعشى يعرف وادينار وربما سلك هذا الوادي
عندما ذهب الى الحجاز
[موسيقى]
لتعويض ما اخفته ايادي الزمن قام عيد
اليحيى ببحث اكاديمي وميداني ثم ذهبت
كاميرات العربيه توثق اوديه حجر اليمامه
وابراجها وسدودها حتى قصر المصمك والدرعيه
ثم ذهبت في خطوات اكبر الى جبال العارض
والابكين حيث تمت محاكاه لحظات من حروب
الرده بخيول عربيه اصيله على صهواتها
فرسان استخدموا سيوفا ودروعا واقواسا خرجت
من متحفها للمره الاولى
طاحت العربيه